hey uh we're going to look at a couple
clips of Infowars conspiracy theorist
Alex Jones you guys remember Alex Jones
right that guy
um Alex Jones has some new conspiracy
theories including some that he
explained to Steve Bannon which we'll
get to
that are so complicated and so
ridiculous that even his own followers
don't get them and you know what I also
don't get them because they don't make
any sense let's start with the first one
it's something about Count Dracula the
operating system of the sax Coburg gotha
families right which is the oldest
bloodline
of European Bloodlines in the world in
which all European bloodlines
agree are their progenitors going back
to their founder Vlad the Impaler
Count Dracula is the recognized head of
the entire Dynasty there you go
and so this house of the dragon that
flies the dragon Banner the drakul
rule the planet
um just like Revelation tells us the
Dragon
and
it's allied with the other Dragon the
child comes
and its goal is yeah the operating
system uh Chewbacca reportedly also
plays a pretty major role in this one
um it doesn't even sound like Alex Jones
understands what he's talking about here
uh in this next clip he actually he
being Alex Jones actually interviewed
Steve Bannon hot off of his conviction
and he tries to explain one of these
crazy globalist conspiracy theories to
Steve Bannon globalist internationalist
trotskyite socialist unlike Obama
trudeoma Crown okay that was actually me
okay but here's the actual Alex Jones uh
explanation to Bannon say no no this is
good you need pain booty judges said and
and Grand home and all of them we're
doing this in a transition but it's not
a transition into a better Star Trek
civilization it's a transition into a
new feudal estate literally cutting off
the energy to make everybody poor and
dumb down feudalism 2.0 uh and so that's
that's what the great reset is that's
what Klaus Schwab is uh that's what this
professor of medieval studies arari is
none of those are his ideas that's all
been said with the club of Rome it's all
been set by the Bilderberg Group it's
all been said by lemons to growth you
know it's all been said by the
population bomb it's all been said in
ecoscience uh you know written in the
70s
by the man that later became Obama's uh
you know science are and when you read
this stuff if you just
[ __ ] back and look at it you know this
is the closest thing to Hitler I've ever
seen just sit back guys this is like
Hitler
5.0 this is like Hitler Buck Rogers
level right the other funny thing is
Alex Jones acting like Hitler is bad
here which is another thing you don't
necessarily always assume Alex Jones
will say okay so here's one more and in
this one this is now back to Alex Jones
Show and he says in this one that the
attack has started the popular the
depopulation has started there's a
second Atlantis happening and something
about nanotechnology and they're going
to take the food and they're going to
wipe everybody out why it's never clear
it's here a second Atlantis and you know
how Atlantis ended
and America was founded
by Francis Bacon and others to be the
new Atlantis
and so that's where we are and the
decision has been made and you can see
the arguments are there especially the
public doesn't say no to this this is a
test to go ahead and wipe out
90 plus percent of the population
and quite frankly if the population
doesn't care it doesn't get engaged
doesn't get involved the population does
deserve the time the children don't but
definitely the adults and the slobs and
the decadent people uh that that that
think they're winning in this corrupt
system and think this is all funny those
people deserve to die I'm not going to
kill them we shouldn't kill them but I'm
simply explaining that they're
projecting their own loathing of
themselves onto us and they want us to
die do you think I mean so one question
is do you understand this but the more
important thing is do you think it's
even designed for Jones audience to
understand or it's just they're supposed
to hear his confidence and the buzzwords
and go that makes a lot of sense without
even understanding it like arguably it's
designed not to be understood and I'm
simply telling them don't worry you're
not going to have to wait long you're
going to be in a Topia and die too
go ahead and pretend like you're part of
the power structure or not but then
there's the real luciferians right on
top
who actually believe Lucifer's God
they're bringing balance to the universe
and they're very sad about what they
have to do and this is all part of a
greater plan they're instruments of this
uh incredible
transformation that they call it
this Transcendence that's happening
so
they've already begun injecting people
with the time delayed kill switches yep
uh it's they're already spraying us with
nanotech they're already putting in all
the food it's the attack has begun yep
and uh so that kill switch basically you
get injected with the kill switch or uh
you eat it and then at any point someone
can basically flip a switch maybe Klaus
Schwab or you know often the people who
have this access to the switch are Jews
in these conspiracy theories
um they can just flip the switch and
kill you when you're no longer useful to
them and as you notice there's a lot of
vague them and they in all of these
hypotheses and that is all completely by
Design
um again we don't make fundamental
illness we don't stigmatize it but these
are the sorts of paranoid delusions that
you would often look at medication for
and it is a guy who has built an
audience around it extremely scary stuff